normalerweise kann man mir mein snapshot
account keine snap sein allerdings habe
ich diese option für gestern abend für
drei minuten mal deaktiviert und bei
twitter geschrieben schickt mir eure
behinderten self das ist teil einer
neuen serie eventuell und zwar dafür
auch einmal pad bestellt was man scheiße
jedenfalls kam unter anderem soll was
ist das was was ist das ich hab mir fünf
coole zelt ist raus wird und zwar dem
typ mir tut mir diesen gib mir dieses
etwas hier und dieses mädchen mit ihrer
katze und ich werde jetzt versuchen
diese leute nach zu malen sparen wir
einfach mit diesem hübschen mädchen hier
an und zwar stelle ich die deckkraft
einfach 50 prozent habe darunter eine
weite ebene und werde jetzt versuchen
mit einem mal innerhalb von drei minuten
das ganze so schön wie möglich zumal das
heißt die werde hier die zeit stoppen
ich bekannt wahrscheinlich keinen time
einblenden
aber ich fange jetzt einfach mal an
liest michael hinzu
dazu muss ich sagen dass ich überhaupt
nicht mahlen kann das heißt die serie
wird wahrscheinlich verdammt witzig für
euch also ich zeig euch das jetzt mal
hier
da timer starten drei minuten er läuft
runter und wir fangen jetzt an wenn ihr
euch denken im alten der die an ich
mache zuerst mal die hautfarbe so ein
bisschen und das krasse ist ja ich muss
mich dabei richtig feierlich die switche
zurzeit immer noch so zwischen oder
vereine mit bronner herrscht switche
derzeit immer noch ein bisschen zwischen
mal stick und maus weil ich noch nicht
ganz richtig damit klarkomme aber ich
versuche das ganze irgendwie zu kriegen
müsste mir leid wenn ich jetzt total vom
vermischt alte du wo mein gott timer
sagt noch eine minute 50 das heißt ich
muss mich wahrscheinlich sogar richtig
bei allen es ist das allererste bild was
ich mit mal ich hab es ja nur ein
bisschen getestet dass ich so ein
bisschen mit dem stift überhaupt klar
komme aber jetzt das erste oh mein gott
dass das wird ja so ein chaos
es wird schon die farbe jetzt mal so ein
bisschen zu brauen damit ich hier so
diese wimpern hier so ein bisschen hin
gemacht dass er kein wunder dass in der
augenbrauen zweimal sagt noch eine
minute sieben das heißt ich ziehe jetzt
mal ein bisschen durch werde hier noch
so ein bisschen was schönes machen jetzt
mache ich mal eben hier noch die
deckkraft so ein bisschen runter so
vielleicht auf 80 damit die nase so ein
bisschen
hier ganz schön hier kommt noch so schön
die nase so ein bisschen rum auf den
mond komplett vergesst nicht spaß mit
freunde der teilweise noch 30 sekunden
das ist nicht wahr
30 25 sekunden scheiße der den final
countdown freundin macht jetzt noch eben
schnell die zähne so ein bisschen
oh mein gott freunde der timer erst
gerade ausgegangen ist hat gerade
angefangen hier zu klingeln
und jetzt jetzt wie mache ich wie kann
ich denn jetzt hier macht macht das mal
aus jetzt das zum thema apple klasse ich
klicke auf anhalten nix geht jetzt
kommen wir zum moment der wahrheit für
das erste bild ich drehe die deckkraft
mal wieder hoch auf 100 prozent also so
sah es vorher aus meine lieben freunde
und jetzt meine zeichen ok ich meine das
ursprungs bild nichts gegen dich aber
ist jetzt auch nicht so hübsch aber
meine zeichnung
also ich finde ich habe es eigentlich
ganz gut getroffen wenn ich mal hier
sollen so ein bisschen immer zur seite
gehe und das thema ziehe
naja also glaubt mir da sich die
benutzer geht's eigentlich klar
so freuen und man hätte das zweite bild
hier der timer läuft wieder drei minuten
läuft runter und jetzt geht's auch schon
direkt platz
übrigens der ein oder andere eventuell
sagen sollte wie kann zudem solche
schlimmen bilder von seinen abonnenten
mit ins video nehmen ich habe euch
gesagt bei twitter ihr könnte damit
eventuell ins video kommen und das haben
so viele gemacht das heißt sie haben
damit quasi eingewilligt dass ich hier
die veranstalten davor dieser katze hat
das ok die hatte wahrscheinlich keine
entscheidungsmacht darüber okay bei
diesem bild hier bin ich mir sehr sicher
dass das ganze ziemlich scheiße aussehen
wird die zeit ist knapp die hälfte der
zeit und ich habe noch keinen einzigen
konturen getan
oh mein gott freundlich kommt überhaupt
nicht klar die letzten sekunden ich
versuche jetzt noch irgendwie irgendwas
rauskriegen das ist nicht wahr ich muss
auf jeden fall noch schnell irgendwie
die dings werde ich dringend die haare
sonst kann ich das ding nein ich wollte
ok der timer ist vorbei und jetzt
stellen wir hier wieder die deckkraft
man eben auf 100 prozent der mitglieder
wieder vergleichen können also freunde
das ergebnis wir haben hier als grund
ausgangsbild haben wir dieses bild meine
version davon
aber irgendwie schon besser erkennen als
das andere oder gibt euch das an
ach ich hab die katze die katze sieht
der komplett behindert aus vergleicht
man hier das gesicht mit der katze mit
meiner gemalten katze das ist ja so
schrecklich oh mein gott na gut okay
aber ich finde es jetzt eigentlich so
gar nicht mal so schlimm gelungen also
es sieht jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
scheiße aus auf den ersten blick aber
man könne es eventuell als kunst
abstempeln
ich glaube diesmal könnte etwas werden
weil dieses bild nicht so viele details
beinhaltet das ist halt einfach nur
seinen mut mit dem grauen shirt und
einen kopfhörer auf ich denke das sollte
ich eigentlich relativ gut hinkriegen
aber so wie ihr meine zeichen skills
bisher einschätzen können wir das ganze
wahrscheinlich wieder eine totale
mitgestalten das blöde ist da sind immer
so aus schwenker drin weil ich dann aus
versehen zum komischen stift knopf komme
deswegen sieht das immer so als ob er da
so zwischendurch irgend welche kanten
hat also ich mal noch nicht so gerade
ich hatte auch keine kunst lk was man
wahrscheinlich schon erkennen kann aber
wir liegen ganz gut in der zeit die
hälfte der zeit ist vorbei das heißt ich
mal dass hier noch eben schnell aus und
dann müsste ich eigentlich sofort fertig
sein alter was habe ich denn hier mit
seiner kopf dings gemacht wie
verunstalteten richtig es tut mir leid
falls ihr in diesem video eventuell
vorgekommen sei dass ich euch zu solchen
richtigen mist mache das tut mir echt
leid dass wobei ich erschrecke ich dabei
immer wie so ne mittelalter so freunde
das hier ist das grund exemplar und
meine zeit davon ist ich schaue jetzt
auch nicht halt mal die augen zu ihr
könnt jetzt schon mal sehen
ich schaue mir jetzt an hey das geht
eigentlich voll klar oder
also ich meine was diese stehe jeder
vorne bedeuten weil sie nicht aber es
geht eigentlich mega klar finde ich
schaut euch an mein gott also wenn ich
das mit den beiden anderen hier bisher
immer gleiche würde ich wirklich hier
die katze war aufschlag aber das hier
geht und klar eigentlich oder ok freunde
wir machen weiter mit unserem experten
mit unserem baumeister am werk und ich
würde sagen der timer wird gesetzt auf
drei minuten timer start in 32 der timer
läuft und los geht's
wir liegen gut in der zeit freunde eine
minute 40 noch und ich habe das grobe
fertig mache ich hier noch eben schnell
den helden der aufsichtsrat im
hintergrund hängt mario götze ihn im
zimmer
okay vielleicht hätte ich das man gut in
der zeit liegen nicht zu früh sagen
sollen
wir sind richtig scheiße an der zeit wir
haben noch 50 sekunden und ich musste
das komplette gesicht machen sie hatte
gerade keine zeit mehr die farbe zu
wechseln für die augen deswegen werden
die gerade ein bisschen fluffig lila
blau aber ich glaube der teilweise noch
16 sekunden eventuell noch ein bisschen
was verbessern wir machen mal ganz
schnell hier noch irgendwas wie machen
wir haben das ohr komplett vergessen wir
larrys jetzt schon dass das total cup ok
freunde die ursprüngliche version und
jetzt meine gemalte version sieht so aus
um ein fucking gott
das kann doch nicht sein alter als ob
ich so einen schicker gezeichnet haben
schaut euch das mal an dieser
unterschied das ist doch nicht
auszuhalten waren ja gut als ich meine
natürlich wenn man das vorjährige bild
kennen dann weil er das t shirt ist
misslungen die lippen eigentlich ist
alles müssen sogar die nase sieht
einfach aus spaß knopf was das video bei
mir nach rund 40 minuten lang das habe
ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt kein interesse
mehr daran noch hier den letzten du zu
machen vor allem das bild ist auch mega
wackelt tut mir leid oder sei froh dass
ich nicht auch noch zur grunde macht das
würde ich sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr das nicht
wahrhaben wollte dass ich das noch mal
machen oder so dann wieso focus east du
mich nicht fest
dann zeigt es mir mit einem kommentar
bewertung teilt das video zeigt seinen
freunden und jetzt das video oder ich
ziehe mir meine hose aus gute
entscheidung